Professor John Merriman:
I'll tell you my favorite
midterm story.
Maybe one or two of you have
heard this before.
The point of this is that you
don't screw around with midterms
because people put their game
faces on;
you're going to have your game
faces on, on Monday.
But maybe ten years ago
somebody in the first half of
this class raised their hand the
day before,
the lecture before the midterm
and said, oddly enough,
"what language will the midterm
be in?"
And this is before we had
French-speaking sections.
So, I don't know,
you ask a question that was a
fairly silly question,
you give a fairly silly answer.
So, I said "Croatian."
And, so, then I started
thinking, well I'll play a
little joke on them;
"ha-ha, don't screw around with
midterms."
And, so, I have a colleague who
is Croatian and so I made up the
following question,
which he translated into
Croatian.
And, so, the test,
you come into the test and you
get your basic piece of paper,
it says answer one of the
following two questions,
and there's a third question,
in Croatian,
with a translation by Ivo
Banac.
And the question was mine,
I take full credit or discredit
for this.
The question was,
"the population of Paris in
1831 was 630,721 people;
name these people,
and in a second column list
those who owned more than one
apartment."
So, if you got a question that
said the population of Paris was
630,731, name these people,
would you answer that question?
Three people did.
So you have to think,
what have they been drinking,
what have they been smoking?
And, so, what do we do?
I'm screwing around with a
midterm, and we have three blue
books answering question number
three in Croatian;
not responding in Croatian,
that would be extra credit.
And the first person says,
well, logically enough--people
must panic.
I must have done this too when
I showed up late for midterms or
whatever, if I remembered to go,
you just--you panic and you
start writing.
And the first person said,
"well, Merriman,
he's real interested in social
geography,"
so he wrote a pretty coherent
essay about how the rich people
live in the west and the poorer
people live in the east and the
wealthier people in the center,
and the poor people on the
periphery."
So, we graded that as a real
answer.
Person number two takes pen--I
don't remember male or
female--person number two takes
pen and starts writing a column:
Albert Hassin,
Jean Claude,
Jean Marie, Albert Hassin,
Xavier--and writes names,
writes French names;
sitting there for forty-five
minutes writing names.
What do you do with that?
Call psychiatric services,
I don't know.
I got to deal with this stuff,
you know.
And, so, the third person says,
"Question Number Three," and
then just sort of just drooled
all over the blue book,
for about the next half hour.
And, so, we get these things,
get this soggy blue book,
and you get one with a kind of
a half-assed but still okay
essay on social geography,
and you get the third,
it's a bunch of names.
So, what do you?
How do you grade that?
We had a council of--a meeting
to discuss this,
and I don't know what we did.
I know we gave the first person
some sort of B+ for the essay,
and number two I think I
convoked the person and maybe
called the college dean to say
"Ça va?
Ça ne vas pas?
Ça marche?
Ça ne marche pas?
On a un petit problème
quand même,
nous."  Anyway,
I don't mean to screw around
with your midterm.
Sorry?
Student: How many names
did he get through?
Professor John Merriman:
Oh, I guess about maybe--I
tore it up at the end.
There was probably about
seventeen or eighteen names,
and they were in alphabetical
order.
So, it wasn't that the midterm
was a total loss.
But that's the last time I
screw around with midterms.
Brian, mon brave,
are your people getting this in
French, the midterm,
or in English?
Brian: Well,
they're getting the French
Department to do French.
Professor John Merriman:
No, but the exam,
when we do the exam in a few
minutes, are we going to do that
in French?
Okay, voilà.
So, let's start.
Where was I?
I got taken out there a little
bit here, thinking about those
old times.
I want today to talk about 1917
and 1918, and talk a little bit
about the mutinies.
The mutinies have to be seen in
the context, of the course,
in all these assaults,
but above all the Battle of the
Somme.
And the Battle of the Somme,
which began on July 1st,
1916 was the darkest moment
certainly in four years of dark
days.
On the first day of the Battle
of the Somme--I always give
these statistics,
they're so interesting--the
first day, the 1st of July,
1916, almost 40,000 British
soldiers were killed in one day,
and--I mean 40,000,
sorry, were wounded,
and 20,000 were killed on the
very first day.
There was a casualty for every
half meter of the entire front
line;
so, one casualty for every half
meter of the front line.
And I gave this statistic the
first day, when I was kind of
giving an overview of the
course,
but there were more British
soldiers killed or seriously
wounded in the first three days
of the Battle of the Somme than
there were Americans killed in
World War One,
Korea, and Vietnam combined.
And you can include the 4,000
that had been killed in this
current third war.
So, those are phenomenal losses.
And, so, the question again
when you look at the poisoning
of the political atmosphere and
the absence of able leadership
in Europe in the 1920s and
1930s,
where were they?
In the case of Britain they
were, as that poem went,
hung up on that old barbed
wire, because they were dead.
And sometimes it's easy--and
British society is such a class
society, and it's easy to kind
of poke fun at Oxbridge folks
going to their common room,
and then going off to
machinegun Indian insurgents,
and this sort of thing.
But the flower of British youth
perished and the flower of other
countries' youth during this
time.
And, so, the mutinies have to
be seen in that context;
and I'll come back to them in
awhile.
Now, 1917 is the crucial year,
really, in determining the
outcome of a war that seemed
like it was going to go on
forever;
forever, not defined by truly
forever, but that in the end of
1917 and the beginning of 1918,
into March--well,
after they slow down the
Ludendorff offensive in 1918,
the military planners begin to
think that they'll win the war
in 1920,
1921 maybe, if all went
spectacularly well in 1919.
And, of course,
as so many people died to win a
few hundred meters,
or a kilometer,
or two kilometers,
or three kilometers at best,
there were wags who said well
at this rate we'll reach the
Rhine,
somebody figured out,
by the year 2007,
which is where we are now,
more or less,
if I remember that statistic.
But two things happen in 1917
that are essential.
One is that the Bolshevik
Revolution comes along;
but first the revolution in
February where the people of St.
Petersberg wake up and find
that the emperor has no clothes,
that there's police but no
troops,
and the bread lines are long,
and the czarist autocracy
falls, leading to that sort of
power vacuum and Kerensky's
provisional government.
And, of course,
in October the Bolsheviks,
after one attempt had failed,
the Bolsheviks seize power.
And at that point the war
changes dimensions dramatically
in the east.
Russia is still in the war
until the Treaty of
Brest-Litovsk in March of 1918.
But the propaganda,
which was more than that of
war, bread, and peace--that's a
motto to live by--means that
you've got a de-acceleration in
the Russian war effort and
you've got massive desertions
from the Russian Army.
Now, one of the amazing things
is that the desertion rate was
so low, compared to what you
think would happen.
And it is rather amazing that
the Russians were able to hold
on, again, just as the Germans
were close to Paris,
particularly in March 1918;
the German forces are also
quite close to Petrograd,
that St.
Petersberg had been renamed
because Petrograd sounded more
Russian.
But the other thing that
changes the outcome of the war
is that the Americans come in.
And in the United States--the
United States were supposedly
neutral until 1917,
but outside of places with
strong German populations,
for example Philadelphia,
Milwaukee, Chicago,
the majority of Americans
supported the Allies,
as defined by the British,
the French and the Russians,
and particularly through the
British component.
But it wasn't really that that
brings the Americans into the
war.
The German High Command--to
make again one of these
interesting long stories very,
very short--had decided that
the only way that they could win
is to knock the British out of
the war,
and the way that they could
knock the British out of the war
is to stop the supply of
munitions,
of food, of grain,
of almost anything else you
could imagine,
to Great Britain.
Now, how are you going to do
that?
Well the way you're going to do
that is with a campaign of
unrestricted submarine warfare,
the famous U-boats,
that sink an incredible number
of ships.
And the German government goes
down, sends representatives down
to the docks in New York and to
other ports,
Boston and other places,
and they put up warnings saying
that the civilian passengers or
any other Americans who go on
ships ought to know that they're
entering a war zone and could be
sunk.
And the German U-boats sink
some ships with Americans on
them.
The most dramatic event was the
sinking of the Lusitania,
which I'm sure you all know
about,
in which lots of Americans--I
can't remember how many,
but it was hundreds and
hundreds;
it might've even been 1,000;
I apologize for not have the
statistic in my head--were
killed, off, I think it's fairly
near Ireland.
And, of course,
the Americans go wild and say
that this ship was carrying
passengers going over to Britain
and civilians,
and this was an act of piracy,
an act of war,
an act of murder,
et cetera, et cetera.
It turns out that I think it
was in the 1960s or 1970s,
I vaguely remember this,
that they sent divers down into
the Lusitania and they found
that, as the Germans had
claimed,
it was absolutely correct that
the Americans were--this ship
was carrying munitions and
therefore--I'm not defending the
sinking of the ship,
I'm not for the defending of
the sinking of any ship--but
clearly it was carrying weapons,
and that's one of the reasons
that the ship went down with
such a dramatic impact is
because all the munitions blew
up when the German torpedo hit
it.
But over the long run what
happens is that the man who was
going to keep America out of
war,
Woodrow Wilson,
former President of Princeton
University, ends up taking the
U.S.
into war.
And those of you who have had
American History from Glenda or
other people,
Glenda Gilmore or other folks
here,
will know that in the end most
Americans really didn't want to
go to war.
And Wilson, wbo was the first
American President,
by the way, ever to leave the
United States during a term of
office,
goes to Versailles,
to the Treaty of Versailles
after the war,
and then he can't get the
treaty ever ratified by the U.S.
Congress after that.
His repudiation is really
complete, unfortunately for him,
at the end of the war.
Now, what difference did the
Americans coming into the war
mean, in 1917?
It was not the troops--lots of
troops begin to arrive,
led by Pershing,
John Pershing,
who had honed his skills by
shooting down Mexicans in
Mexico.
And they have the reputation
for being sort of cowboys in
earnest, and sort of the typical
American image is
really--although that's been
devastated in the last four or
five years--but really is
created by the Americans
arriving to fight,
and they're well-trained,
pistol-wielding sharpshooters
and all that.
And they first go to- they
first fight at
Château-Thierry,
which is not very far from
Paris, it's northeast of Paris,
in 1917.
But that's not what makes the
difference.
American troops in the long run
will help tilt the scale to the
Allies, and it compensates for
what we've discussed in terms of
the French not having--they're
going to run out of soldiers.
But the big difference is that
the curves cross,
that the curves of the ability
of the Germans to supply their
own forces;
that the German war machine is
not going to be able to compete
with the combined power of
American industrial might,
and Detroit can be easily
converted--the factories in
Detroit, and Ypsilanti,
and Flint, Michigan,
and lots of other places,
can be easily transformed into
production of--Ypsilanti into
the production of arms,
and places like that.
And, so, the curves cross.
And it's at that point when
many people in the French and
the British High Command,
along with the Americans--they
know they're going to win the
war in the long run,
but the question, at what cost?
And there's lively discussion,
as there had been in Germany,
over German war aims.
The Germans,
if they win the war in the west
they're going to want--demand
part of Belgium,
they're going to want probably
more of Lorraine,
et cetera, et cetera.
The French also have their war
aims.
They're going to want to have a
permanent French presence;
they're talking about that in
the Rhineland as well as taking
Alsace and Lorraine back.
And so that helps set up--which
I'll come back to talk about in
awhile--1918,
March, because that's when the
Germans say, "baby it's now or
never."
And, so, that's the big
Ludendorff offensive,
which I'll come back to,
in March of 1918.
That's important to say,
to discuss at least a little
bit.
Now, what about the mutinies
and what about other aspects of
the war?
They have to do with the home
front.
And the mutinies are not on the
home front but they're quite
close to it.
As I said at the beginning
here, most people in France did
not want war in 1914,
but because it was easy to
portray Germany as the
aggressors, which they were,
the vast majority of the
population obviously was
prepared to hold on because of
the proximity certainly of Paris
to the front;
and this is right through the
war, it's right through into the
failure of the Ludendorff
offensive.
Now, to be sure there are
tensions within French society
about the war.
There was tremendous
resentment, and you can see
photos of this resentment,
as in Paris the opera was one
place where they distributed
coal,
that was rationed,
in order to have heat.
And as you know from discussion
previously of the Grands
Boulevards, that's where many of
the famous restaurants and
cafés,
the Café
American, the Café
de la Paix, ironically the
Café de la Paix,
the café
of peace, and all those things
are located.
And, so, as people waited in
line to hope to get a few chunks
of coal in order to stay warm in
these cold Parisian winters,
they saw the fancy people in
their big cars,
driven by chauffeurs,
going off to the great
restaurants,
and people who had profiteered
from the war.
And name me a war in which
people do not profit enormously
and in which some aspects of big
business are not just gleeful
with every extended tour of
duty,
and you'll have discovered
something that I didn't know
existed.
And, so, there's a lot of
tension toward profiteers,
to les gros,
the big guys,
the fat guys,
les gros bonnets,
the big hats.
And you've got those tensions.
But you have--more than that
you have tensions between those
people who, peasants,
les paysans,
who are conscripted without any
real possibility,
unless they're already had two
brothers killed,
and that saves them;
and, for example,
skilled workers in the armament
industry.
For example around
Saint-Étienne,
Saint-Étienne is an
armament manufacturing town,
or was--they used to make bikes
there, too.
They don't make either there
anymore.
Or in Tulles,
in the Corrèze,
places that make arms,
people, skilled workers got out
of the draft because of that.
And thus they worked very hard
but there was some tension
towards that from,
for example,
people in the Massif Central
where you have the most endless
lists of names killed that one
could ever see,
in Auvergne and places like
that.
So, you have those sorts of
tensions, as well.
Now, the role of women in all
this is of course crucial
because it's in the factories,
particularly in not highly
skilled work because they didn't
have the formation or the
training in that,
that women step up and replace
men.
And also, again the role of
nurses is so important.
And, so, that's why it was
inconceivable for many French
women, after all of this,
not to get the vote after World
War One;
whereas in Britain women get
the vote after World War Two;
and in the United States Rosie
the Riveter, working in a
factory in Detroit or in
Pittsburgh,
became sort of an icon for sort
of the crypto-feminist movement
in later decades.
So, you have some tensions
there.
You also had workers who would
come back--and of course after
the war, if they were lucky
enough to survive--Bruno Cabanes
will probably talk about this
next week,
after midterm--they get thrown
out;
they're the last hired so
they're the first fired.
And there's some tensions
between males and females over
that, too, because the males had
been out in the trenches,
and they want those jobs back,
and all of that.
But another thing that's rather
interesting is of course the
role of women and the nurses;
and the big,
the northern French nuns and
the Belgian nuns with those huge
hats.
And it was easy to become
anti-clerical,
and we've talked about that
before,
but one of the things that
calms that situation is the role
of the clergy,
and in particular of the female
clergy,
in attending to these horrible,
horrible wounds,
and in some cases going to the
fronts,
working with ambulances and
this sort of thing,
as other women did who didn't
happen to be nuns.
And for example the case of
Lyon has been documented;
and Lyon was the capital of
Radical party,
with a big R;
socially conservative and
moderate politically but based
upon, built upon
anti-clericalism.
And in Lyon where there was
this vibrant kind of
anti-clericalism,
before World War I,
that calms down because these
nuns who people attacked,
representing in some ways the
institutionalized role of the
Catholic Church in French
society,
were extraordinarily heroic,
and so were these priests,
and ministers,
and indeed rabbis,
who of course get killed by
shells as they're giving the
last rights to all these people
who have been killed.
And there's another tension too
that's not talked about so much,
but I can--I've heard it in the
sort of collective memory of
where we live too,
is that one of the things that
happens with the war--and
obviously when you look at a map
of France--that
départements like
the Ardennes,
and the Ain,
and the Marne,
and the Pas-de-Calais,
and the Nord are basically
German,
or the front line is running
right through that
département.
So, you've got these millions
of people who become refugees
and they are going--in a more
organized fashion than in 1940
when everybody's seen the
pictures of them walking along
the roads,
carrying what they can,
and then diving into the
ditches as the Luftwaffe,
the German fighter plane,
the German air force is
strafing them,
in a more organized fashion.
But you still have to have
somewhere to go,
you have to have someplace to
end up where you're going to be
fed.
And, so, where do they end up?
Well, they end up in the places
in France where there is not
fighting.
And it became that people get
tired of the war by 1917--well,
everybody's tired of the war.
But as one gets even tireder of
the war you hear this sort of
grumbling about these people
from the north,
and they speak a different
accent in some cases--if they
speak German they speak a
different language;
if they speak Flemish,
and there are lots of Flemish
speakers who come down from the
Nord, from places like Hasbrouck
and all of that.
And, so, they are strains on
local resources,
which are already extremely
limited.
And, so, you even have this
talk, grumbling,
it's not more than that,
but grumbling in cafés
and bars about Paris's war,
but also about les borschts
du nord, that is the Germans
of the north.
And one of the things is that a
lot of people in the north of
France are blonde,
and a lot of people,
the majority of the people in
the south of France have dark
hair.
And, so, all of a sudden
there's this arrival--it was a
silly way of viewing it,
but this is how people viewed
it, is that you had your blonde
people in the south and you have
dark people in the north,
that life is like that.
But you have the arrival of
these people,
many of whom look like they're
Dutch,
who're arriving and who cause
some sort of strain on the
ability of communities to take
care of those perceived as of
their own.
And, so, 1917 is a big year for
that as well.
You have other kinds of
problems.
1917 is the year lots of men
and women go on strike.
Now, they are not,
these are not "defeatist",
in quotes, strikes,
but the strikes in
Saint-Étienne,
and many of them are involving
women, are demands for better
working conditions,
for better wages.
They're part of the Sacred
Union, Union
Sacrée,
but they want better
conditions.
And, so, the strikes in 1917,
again they're not defeatist
strikes, they want to win the
war,
but it's the same thing as the
movement before the war for
better conditions.
Why should you work for worse
conditions than men,
for example,
or why should you work for
conditions when the profiteers
are getting rich and the gros
bonnets,
the big bonnets,
the big hats are getting
wealthy, why should you have
terrible conditions?
And, so, these strikes are very
widespread.
Clemenceau has more power;
in 1917 he becomes prime
minister, he says,
"I wage war,
I wage war, I wage war,
that's all."
There were attempts to break
the strikes but it's a year
where the morale of the home
front is extremely fragile.
It's more fragile in 1917 than
in any other time.
And there seems to be this
enormous disparity between the
sort of howling propaganda of
big newspapers,
in which everything is a great
victory and defeats are just
tiny setbacks,
a step back;
and if things are so damn good
why are the Germans still close
to Paris?
And, so, it becomes pretty hard
to explain.
Now, they don't have the
problems that the Germans will
have because--and that's a
different situation.
A very good book edited by my
friend Jay Winter and Jean-Louis
Robert called Capital Cities
at War--because conditions
are worse in Berlin than they
are in Paris.
But conditions are much better
in London than they are in
Paris, and that's for fairly
obvious reasons,
though the losses are still
equally bad.
So, that year,
1917, is a bad year but overall
things are calmed down and for
these reasons I've already said
it is a turning point.
Now, what about these,
the mutinies?
How serious were the mutinies?
There were probably only two
divisions that were totally
reliable, standing between the
Germans and Paris,
at that point.
Not reliable again to the
extent that they want the
Germans to win,
because they don't,
but they want,
for example,
the rights--the French were
trying to keep representatives
from the Socialist Party from
going to Switzerland or going to
Sweden to meet in international
peace conferences,
and that sort of thing.
I spoke earlier,
whenever it was,
Monday, about this sort of
discontinuity or the contrast
between the soldiers' view of
the war and that of the
civilians--and one of the--and
how the soldiers back on leave
didn't want to talk about it and
couldn't really give that
precise kinds of information
anyway,
because often it's all swirling
around them and they don't
really know what's going on in
other places except where they
are.
But one of the best evidences
of that is the fact that nobody,
as far as we can tell,
at the home front really knew,
at the time of the mutinies,
about how serious and
widespread the mutinies were,
that they didn't really know.
Now, remember also that--in
fact, this is one of the key
sources for Bruno Cabanes'
magnificent book on--the
translation to English would be
something like Victory
Plunged into Mourning,
that is the return of the
soldiers.
One of the principal sources
are letters written by soldiers
from the front that were
collected and censored by
military censors who don't want
these letters revealing to
civilians much of what was going
on at all.
And, so, that also explains why
people at the home front really
didn't know about how widespread
these mutinies were,
nor did the Germans,
nor did the British,
outside of High Command,
have any sense of what was
going on.
Now, these mutinies,
it's not too hard to say why
these mutinies take place when
they do, or why they take place
at all.
It is not again defeatism,
they don't want the Germans to
win.
They have some respect,
lots of respect for the German
soldiers they're fighting
against,
although at the end of the war
they still just sort of--what
seeps out of these letters--and
maybe Bruno will talk about this
next time,
is hatred for the horrible Hun,
et cetera, et cetera,
but that anybody could tell
that these tactics were just
killing hundreds of thousands of
people for nothing,
for nothing,
that there wasn't going to be a
French-British breakthrough;
that the Battle of the Somme
grounds to a halt,
all along the front,
for obvious reasons,
after a matter of really days
but weeks, and that there isn't
any hope.
It began when one company-- Oh,
by the way, how do we know
this?
We don't know it from Kirk
Douglas.
Most archives in France can be
opened up fifty years after the
fact.
So, what year is this?
2000 something or other, 2007.
So, we can see the archives
fifty years ago,
but not forty-nine years ago.
But with the military archives,
because this was so sensitive,
the mutinies,
all of these documents were in
the war archives in Vincennes.
And I saw them before they were
open because I bribed my way in,
not to see them,
I was working on something else
but the person that ran this,
the war archives was just
totally clueless,
and she'd leave for about three
hour trysts or lunch breaks I
guess,
more appropriately.
And I knew these documents were
there and so I knew also,
somebody had tipped me off that
the gardien likes stamps,
and so I would put all these
wild sort of stamps on my mail,
letters, when people still used
stamps;
I had ones from Latin America
and ones from Africa.
And this guy comes up and he
says, "oh, very beautiful these
stamps."
I said, "oh,
do you like stamps?"
And he'd be, "yes, yes."
"Well would you like these?"
"Oh, thank you so much."
And pretty soon I'm in the
archives, in the back.
And he's an officer too,
he's some sort of lieutenant
guy--he's a real good guy.
Anyway, so I bribed my way in,
and you could see these,
all these cartons,
and they were chained,
they were literally all chained
in this big kind of capsule;
it looked like a space capsule
except it was just-- looks like
the basement of Branford College
or something.
But you couldn't get into those
because that was thought to be
the national disgrace that there
had been these mutinies.
And the mutinies were indeed
widespread.
And so what happens is that
refusals to go over the top
simply spread.
They spread like wildfire.
Soldiers say they don't want to
get killed anymore for five
cents a day.
In some places red flags go up
and in some places there are
black flags, which are the flags
of anarchism.
But remember that the
socialists had also joined the
Sacred Union and that Jules
Guesde ends up being Minister of
Transport,
or Minister of Communication,
or something like that,
in 1915, if I remember
correctly.
And two regiments that are
posted in Soissons--Soissons is
not very far away from Paris,
Soissons is about a forty-five
minute drive away from Paris,
by car now.
Two regiments decide they're
going to march on Paris to try
to set things right.
They're going to force the
Chamber of Deputies to find a
way to end the war;
not to say we want the Germans
to win but to find a way,
get some sort of negotiated
settlement, so that this carnage
stopped.
Most of the generals,
who are fairly clueless,
see organized Bolshevik
propaganda behind this;
or pacifists,
those people coming out of
Sweden or Switzerland and trying
to stop the useless way this war
is being fought.
In May and June about 40,000
soldiers were involved in
collective acts of refusal,
and although the generals
insisted in their correspondence
that those 40,000 people were
cowards--this obviously was not
the case,
and many of them had already
been shot up,
and already been wounded,
and already were going back.
And the first signs of this,
by the way, are that soldiers
who were supposed to move up in
order to prepare to go over the
top begin baaing like sheep,
going baa, baa,
the way that sheep baah on the
way to the slaughter,
l'abattoir,
the slaughterhouse,
because that's where they were
going.
Now, there was socialist and
pacifist literature that had,
happily enough,
in my view, had gotten into the
trenches.
But this is not the motivation.
And Pétain,
who ends up being one of the
sort of evil forces in
France--but this was early
Pétain,
when Pétain,
he realizes that this is not
the case, that in fact the
repression is much less severe
than many of the generals
wanted--more about that in a
minute.
And, so, he ends the policy,
Pétain does,
of these mad attacks;
over the top,
the whistles blow,
and then they simply get
slaughtered.
In some areas--and we don't
have exact statistics because
there were certainly some people
who were just put up against the
wall and shot,
we don't know.
It's just like after 1945,
we don't know,
we have a guess of 10,000
people were killed in the
reprisals in 1945 but that's a
pretty rough account.
But there were 34,027
condemnations,
about ten percent of the people
who were--who faced some kind of
court-martial for something they
did or something they didn't do.
And forty-nine were condemned
to death, which is not--I'm not
for condemning anybody to death
but it--and then these were
carried out as in the movie,
as in the film, immediately.
It's just up against the wall,
bang, bang.
And Pétain tries to,
he tries to bring in better
conditions.
He ups the booze ration as
well, and of course that was
pretty happy.
So, and in fact I said 40,000,
but there's another statistic
that goes as high as 70,000
people.
And let me throw in a statistic
as long as we're doing that for
strikes.
In 1917 there were 689 strikes
affecting 300,000
workers--that's a lot,
trois cent mille,
300,000 workers,
and that's compared to
ninety-eight strikes in 1916.
But, again, a fascinating
aspect I'm repeating is that
this was not known,
and this was not known--then
you couldn't drive it in
forty-five minutes--but this was
not known in Paris by the
general population,
what had happened.
And in the end France holds on.
Now, in the spring of 1918 the
Germans launch their "victory
drive," in quotes,
the first major German
offensive since 1914;
before it's been the British
and the French attempting to
break through.
Now, at the same time the
Austro-Hungarian Empire--the
army is--all the cracks that
were quite predicted and
predictable,
there are all sorts of problems
there.
And Franz Joseph has died in
1916, and so the Germans are
quite unsure whether the
Austro-Hungarian Empire is going
to be able to hold on fighting
against the Italians,
for example;
and remember that Brest-Litovsk
is not signed until March of
1918.
And the Americans have,
by spring of 1918,325,000
soldiers.
That's not a huge number of
soldiers but that's still three
times Michigan Football Stadium
full.
So, that's a lot of people.
So, Ludendorff decides on a
massive German assault along the
poor old Somme River,
therefore avoiding the mud of
Flanders and avoiding the forts
of eastern France around Verdun.
He was encouraged by the fact
that there are younger soldiers
that are just barely eighteen
that have been put into the
ranks,
and he also has brought up much
older men too.
So, they have some serious
troops in order to try to pull
off this breakthrough.
And, so, on the 21st of March,
1918, after a relatively brief
bombardment of five hours,
as opposed to five days,
1.6 million men--who could have
imagined these numbers,
who could have imagined these
numbers in 1913?--1.6 million
men attack the Allied defenses
in five separate offences over a
front of forty miles.
And they do break through.
In five days some German units
have pushed forward more than
forty miles, and there was--a
complementary attack in Flanders
does very well indeed.
And the British troops and the
French, as General Haigh in
Britain famously once said,
were fighting with their backs
to the wall.
And on Easter Sunday of that
year, again the shells from Big
Bertha lobbed all those miles,
from the north,
fall on Paris.
The Rue de Rivoli,
you can still see a sign where
it took out an apartment
building.
Church of Saint-Gervais,
right near the Seine.
Boulevard Port-Royal,
up by Montparnasse,
the same thing.
So, these shells fall and they
begin taking lives.
But what happens was
predictable and predicted,
is that as on the small scale,
in the big scale the Germans
begin to outrun their cover and
supplies, and they begin at each
one of these five points of
German offensive to encounter
stiff resistance.
On July 15th Ludendorff tries a
last desperate attack and it's
repulsed.
And for Ludendorff,
he knew this was the last
chance to win the war,
and at that point he knows it's
la fin des haricots,
the end of the green beans,
that they're simply not going
to win and that the French,
their resources swollen by the
American entrance into the war,
are not going to sue for an
armistice until they push the
Germans back across the Rhine.
And at that point morale
plunges dangerously in Germany.
In January of 1918,250,000
German workers defy the
government by going on strike;
and strikes were illegal during
the war, there was all sorts of
hoarding, and so there's a big
problem.
And the Allies,
the British,
the French, and the Americans,
counter-attack in July.
And at this point,
when they're in the open for
the first time,
tanks that you've all seen
pictures of them stuck in the
mud,
now when they're in the open
tanks begin to work rather well,
and they begin to adopt the
strategy of having soldiers,
infantry following tanks and
therefore not getting picked off
in such huge numbers,
and they begin to make a big
difference.
On the 8th of August,
1918, the German army's darkest
day, there are all sorts of
attacks against the German lines
and a British force moves eight
miles;
and that's a territory that was
unimaginable in the beginning.
At this point Ludendorff tells
the hapless Wilhelm II that it's
all over but the shouting and
you better figure out some way
of bringing this whole thing to
an end.
And, as you know,
in the end Wilhelm II will
slither across the Dutch border
and the Armistice will be signed
in a railroad car,
in Compiègne,
north of Paris--there's still a
railroad car there,
it's not the same one,
and that's where Hitler
insisted on the declaration of
the Armistice in 1940 being
signed--so the war ends on the
11th of November,
1918.
And, as you know,
there were many people--not
many, but there were lots of
people killed afterwards because
they didn't know that the
Armistice had come along and
that the biggest pandemic ever
in human history,
at least since the Black Death
in the fourteenth century,
the Spanish flu,
as it was called;
it probably started in India
but had already begun to sweep
through the world.
So, things were not getting
better and better but they were
getting worse and worse.
Just a few obvious
statistics--you can see these
all over but it is staggering;
before I end with something
that Jay Winter has begun one of
his books with.
Just in terms of dead and
wounded, just a couple--you can
write these down,
you can write them down or
don't write them down.
But, anyway,
Russia, dead,
1,800,000;
wounded 5,000,000--now,
that ain't nothing like World
War Two, 25,000,000 dead in the
Soviet Union in World War
II--but 1.8 million is a rather
lot to be killed.
In France, the French at
least--and probably more than
this--but you hear figures from
1.4 million to 1.5 million dead;
and wounded 4,266,000.
Great Britain,
including the empire,
the dominion,
the Australians,
the Kenyans,
dead, 908,000 and wounded
2,000,000.
The Italians,
578,000, with about a million
wounded.
And Serbia, which is a very
small country,
dead, 278,000;
wounded 133,000.
Tiny Belgium, killed, 38,000;
wounded 44,000.
And among the Central powers
Germany, 2,000,000 dead,
2,000,000 dead;
after all that with your
armies, how do you explain to
the folks back home all those
people dead, why you
surrendered?
Well, it must be someone's
fault, and that's what the Right
would argue--"it was the Jews,
it was the Socialists,
it was the Communists;
there had to have been a stab
in the back."
How do you explain this to the
folks back home?
Wounded, 4,000,000--more than
that.
Austria-Hungary,
the amazing thing is they held
on so long, given all the
national differences--1.1
million, with wounded 3.6
million.
These are just statistics that
are so incredible.
In France there are 36,000
communes and there were only
twelve that didn't have somebody
killed.
And that's why when you go to
any French commune,
except those twelve,
you'll see a list of those
people killed;
or even inside churches
sometimes they'll have the
parish ones, and if the war
monuments are near the
churches--that tends to happen
more in areas that were still
Christianized,
where people still went to
church;
and I mentioned this once
before, but if you go to the
Bourbonnais or the Allier you
still find these war memorials
that are sort of like Voltaire,
"if God exists,
how could he or she let this
happen?"
With broken crosses,
shattered crosses;
they were lamenting that this
could happen in a so-called
civilized world.
And, of course,
one thing that happens after
the war, as Charles pointed out
the other day,
is that if you've been told--if
you're an African or you're an
Asian and you've been told that
this is the great civilization,
that the Europeans,
they've got it all;
you've been told by them that
they're better than you.
How do you reconcile that to
what they're screaming at you in
their little schools,
trying to teach you their
language?
If they're so damn better how
could they bring all of this
upon Europe?
There is, by the way,
but one soldier left in Great
Britain who's still alive from
World War One.
He's a fellow called Harry
Payne.
He was born in 1898 and
somebody just published a book
about him.
And periodically,
on Armistice Day,
he is interviewed;
you can hear him on BBC.
But with the passing of time of
course you don't have that
anymore.
And I can remember even in my
jeunesse,
I can remember seeing these
very aged people coming out on
November 11th,
so proud of what they did,
fighting.
And the Americans too that did.
But in those days--those were
different wars and those were
different countries,
and I would argue also that was
a very different America.
Anyway, just to simply end with
something that Jay Winter leaves
us with.
He has a wonderful book about
mourning and memory.
And he begins with a film,
he begins with a film by Abel
Gance.
Abel Gance, g-a-n-c-e,
did a very long,
over-rated film on Napoleon,
with the famous snowball fight.
But he did a book--he takes
Zola's title,
but he did a movie called
J'accuse! He makes it in
1918 and 1919;
he made it before the war is
over.
The hero is a guy called Jean
Diaz.
He's a wounded soldier poet and
he goes crazy,
he begins to lose his mind,
as so many people did,
after all that in World War
One, and he escapes from a
mental hospital,
and he goes back to his
village,
and he brings all the villagers
together, and he tells them
about a dream that he's had in
the asylum.
And in the dream,
in the movie,
you see a battlefield graveyard
with all the crosses,
they're all there,
and they're all askew,
and a big black cloud comes up
behind the village graveyard,
in the movie,
and magically these ghost-like
figures emerge from the grave
with tattered bandages,
missing arms--their bandages
begin to unravel around their
head.
And some are blind,
they've lost their sight,
and some are coughing out their
lungs from the poison gas.
And they leave the battlefield
and they go back to their own
villages to see if the
sacrifices have been worth it.
And what they find is what Jay
calls the pettiness of civilian
life, the black-marketing,
the profiteering.
Their wives have been sleeping
around.
Things aren't the way they
should be, whereas they have
suffered.
But they come back,
they're alive again but they're
really dead.
And their appearance so
terrifies the villagers that
they decide to mend their ways
and to become better people,
better people.
And so these ghost-like figures
and their bandages,
they march back to the cemetery
and they go back into their
graves, and it's all over.
But what's really interesting
about it is that some of the
soldiers who were on leave at
that time,
en permission,
were used as extras in the
movie, and you can identify
them--someone who has lost his
arm really,
it's not a fake missing arm,
it's a real one.
And some of them who were
there, in the movie,
go back to the war and are
killed, they die real deaths,
in their graves,
with their tattered bandages.
And it's as if art and reality
have merged.
And that's an important theme
in all of this because there's
no war, no more powerful moment,
in history, that has brought us
such great literature and all of
this.
And there's no war like this
ever that unleashed so many
demons into the world,
and it's some of those demons
that we will now next turn but
not today.
Good luck on the midterm,
have a great weekend.
Rock and roll.